[Music]
your dad is running for the Presidency
United States of America and people are
trying to get to know him and there is
you know all kinds of like what kind of
guy is he and trying to understand who
he is I thought you guys could tell us
who is this MIT Romney what's he all
about first of all you claim that he
likes pranks it does like pranks oh he
doesn't like to get pranked oh and we no
one does like to get pranked out the
hard way we've learned that the hard way
I know we have one of those basements at
our house and when those scary you know
old New England basements is you
probably grew up with and you have to
walk in like three or four steps into
the basement to turn the light you know
pull the light switch down so I heard my
dad coming down the stairs and I turned
the light off and hid back there and so
I saw him walk in the rooms trying to
just it was this by the way this was
this is a while ago okay good so we
didn't have Secret Service protection at
that that's a really stupid night so I
as he's looking for the light I grabbed
his arm in the dark scream in the dark
and it terrified him did he freak did he
scream he shrieked a bit yeah a little
Sheree a little shriek
he turned dad shrieked he turns the
lights on it looks at me and just
tackles me to the ground and says you
know and he's wrestling me to the ground
it goes it wasn't worth it just made it
that much funnier and so I'm like yeah
still worth of dad he keeps harassing me
still worth it yes though worth it
that's a very frightening prank to jump
out at your father in the dark he didn't
like it he didn't like he didn't like it
what prankster does he like to play
pranks and if so what kind of prank does
he like to play yeah he likes to play a
lot of pranks you know I remember a
story from when he was in high school
and I guess his little after high school
and his friend was getting married and
he found his way into the hotel room
ahead of time and all that his the
groom's outfit was there he took some
pink nail polish and wrote on the on the
first shoe AG and the ball on the sole
and the next one LP and no one noticed
it but then when he it was a cap of
wedding and when he knelt down to be
blessed by the father the words help
appeared
very good Frank yeah I'm not sure
they're still friends but no no the wife
wouldn't think that was funny
okay I'm curious did you I've heard a
rumor that your dad likes to get people
to try and smell things and then what
does he do he gay this is a fairly
common price always fall for it I don't
know why we always tell us Matt what
does he do it's this butter is turned
it's so rotten you got to smell it so oh
yeah of course we have to smell it right
away and you go down and right into the
butter or the whipped cream you're
ending up with stuff all over your face
wait a minute okay so he's basically
just smashing your faces into food all
the time
okay and now we do it to our kids you
know naturally well that's as it should
be just a proud Romney heritage which
must be passed down dan I just don't
know is he gonna be doing that kind of
stuff as president you know if he was
the president would it be seeing like
mr. Bernanke I'm worried about these
figures mush
[Laughter]
[Applause]